elena está cultivando plantas de tomate
y estudiando sus alturas con esto obtuvo
los datos siguientes tipos de tomate
bola roma cereza altura en pies 31
cuarto 27 octavos 31 medio cuál es la
diferencia entre las alturas de la
planta de tomate tipo bola bola bola
esto es muy importante y por cierto la
altura en pies de el tomate tipo bola es
tres enteros un cuarto con respecto a la
altura del tomate tipo roma del tomate
tipo romano cuya altura en pies es dos
enteros siete octavos ok esto es de lujo
y esencialmente como preguntan la
diferencia en lo que me tengo que tomar
es la resta de tres enteros de tres
enteros un cuarto ok ya esto restarle
les voy a quitar
dos enteros siete octavos dos enteros
siete octavos y me estoy tomando la
diferencia de dos fracciones que son
números mixtos y cómo puedo hacer esto
bueno primero voy a escribir este número
mixto tres enteros un cuarto como una
fracción impropia voy a pasar de un
número mixto a una fracción impropia y
para esto quiero recordarte que tres
enteros un cuarto es lo mismo que tres
más un cuarto que por cierto es lo mismo
que 33 lo podemos ver como doce cuartos
como doce cuartos más un cuarto un
cuarto date cuenta que doce cuartos es
lo mismo que tres enteros y un cuarto es
este que tengo aquí y bueno a esto le
tengo que quitar dos enteros siete
octavos y utilizando la misma lógica voy
a escribir como dos más siete octavos
pero dos visto en octavos es exactamente
lo mismo que dieciséis octavos dieciséis
octavos y a esto le voy a sumar
octavos siete octavos esto porque 16
octavos es lo mismo que dos enteros
entonces hasta aquí vamos bien ahora
para no complicarle las cosas utilizando
la multiplicación por este signo primero
voy a tomar las respectivas sumas y aquí
tengo doce cuartos más un cuarto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que trece cuartos
que trece cuartos lo cual le voy a
quitar le voy a quitar a dieciséis
octavos más siete octavos lo cual es lo
mismo que 7 16 es 20 323 octavos de lujo
ahora quiero que te des cuenta que tres
enteros un cuarto es exactamente lo
mismo que trece cuartos ya lo escribí
con fracción impropia y de igual manera
este el número mixto dos enteros siete
octavos lo transformé en fracción
impropia como 23 octavos y lo que quiero
saber es la diferencia de estos dos sin
embargo el grave problema que tenemos es
que no tenemos el mismo denominador esta
fracción tiene como denominador el 4
mientras que ésta tiene como denominador
por lo tanto necesitamos encontrar un
denominador común en mi denominador
común entre 8 y 4 es el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 8 y 4 sin embargo 8 es un
múltiplo de 4 de hecho 4 por 2 es 8 por
lo tanto el mínimo común múltiplo entre
8 4 va a ser 8 de lujo así que puedo
transformar estas fracciones y déjenme
bajar un poco la pantalla voy a bajar un
poco la pantalla y justo como por aquí
ok
todo que se vea con un denominador común
de 8 por lo tanto el club escribir 13
cuartos como algo que tiene que ver con
8 y bueno 23 octavos lo voy a escribir
con algo que tienen que ver con 8 pero
por cierto 23 octavos visto con un
denominador de 8 pues es exactamente lo
mismo es lo mismo que 23 sobre 8 ok aquí
tengo un menos y ahora date cuenta que
para pasar de este 13 cuartos a una
fracción cuyo denominador tenga 8 lo que
hice fue multiplicar el denominador por
2 multiplique esta parte de abajo por 2
y si multiplicó el denominador
debajo de esta fracción por dos para que
la fracción se mantenga tengo que
multiplicar la parte de arriba por lo
mismo por dos así que 13 por 2
es lo mismo que 26 26 octavos perfecto
yo lo que quiero tomarme es la
diferencia de 26 octavos menos 23
octavos y ya tengo un denominador común
por lo tanto esto está muy fácil esto es
lo mismo que 8 voy a poner aquí el
denominador común y arriba tengo la
diferencia de 26 26 - 23 octavos menos
veintitrés ok y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 26 menos 23 lo cual es tres
octavos tres octavos es la diferencia
entre estas dos fracciones es decir cuál
es la diferencia entre las alturas de la
planta de tomate tipo bola y la planta
de tomate tipo roma es tres octavos y no
hay que olvidar las unidades estábamos
hablando de que las unidades están dadas
en pies en pies por lo tanto aquí tengo
tres octavos de pie
tres octavos de pie y es justo esa mi
respuesta la diferencia entre las
alturas es tres octavos de pie de lujo